24 лютого минулого року стало фатальним для аеродрому Гостомель.
Тоді російські військові на штурмових вертольотах почали обстрілювати аеропорт та висаджувати ворожий десант.
24 лютого зранку я прибув на роботу.
Ми готувалися до вильоту літака Ан-225,
але вже на той час повітряний простір України був закритий.
Але ми чекали, може буде можливість цей літак випустити з аеропорту, але цього не сталося.
Десь приблизно о 12-й годині з міста Ірпеня ми побачили ворожі гелікоптери,
які одразу почали обстрілювати місце розташування Національної гвардії України.
І в будівлю ангара були влучання.
Наші нацгвардійці прийняли бій і десь 1,5-2 години в аеропорту йшов бій.
Унаслідок боїв за Гостомель було зруйновано інфраструктуру аеродрому і льотно-випробувальну базу.
Збитки підприємство оцінює в 1 мільярд доларів.
Аеродром дуже сильно пошкоджений.
Ви бачите літаки, які мають величезні пошкодження, інфраструктура, ангари.
Але потрошки ми починаємо його відновлювати.
Зараз йдуть експертизи будівель, літаків.
Ви бачили відео, коли тут скрізь була ворожа техніка розбита.
Зараз ми це все прибрали, потихеньку перон і рульові доріжки ми відновлюємо,
щоб можна було переміщати пошкоджені літаки.
Крім того, в аеропорту були знищені та сильно пошкоджені вісім із тринадцяти літаків підприємства.
Серед них і унікальна українська "Мрія" – найбільший вантажний літак у світі, який не підлягає відновленню.
Рік потому СБУ повідомила про підозру екскерівникам ДП "Антонов".
За матеріалами слідства, напередодні повномасштабного вторгнення чиновники
не допустили військових Нацгвардії на територію аеропорту для підготовки його захисту,
що привело до знищення "Мрії".
Зараз у флоті підприємства залишилося 5 літаків АН-124-100 "Руслан".
Вони базуються у німецькому аеропорту Лейпциг/Галле,
який став другою домівкою для літаків ДП "Антонов".
Співпраця розпочалася ще у 2006 році.
І в останні роки тут навіть є ангар для технічного обслуговування повітряних суден цієї компанії.
Зараз працюють над створенням повноцінної бази в німецькому аеропорту.
Раніше співпраця була така, що літаки Антонова були постійними гостями.
Обслуговувалися тут. Звідси вони починали свої відправлення.
Після початку російської загарбницької війни та знищення аеропорту "Гостомель" -
рідного аеропорту "Авіаліній Антонова" - Антонов перебазував літаки,
які ще існували сюди до аеропорту Лейпцига/Галле.
Це означає, що Лейпциг/Галле дійсно став другим домом для "Авіаліній Антонова".
Літаки "Антонова" продовжують виконувати стратегічні вантажні перевезення завдання в інтересах України.
На замовлення НАТО та ЄС.
"Авіалінії Антонова" мають контракт з НАТО вже понад десять років.
Це транспортні завдання для НАТО.
Не лише з Лейпциг/Галле, а й з 14 країн НАТО.
Але звідси літає і комерційний транспорт.
Це означає, що особливо важкі вантажі, які потрібно транспортувати, відправляються з Лейпциг/Галле.
Зараз всі рейси і базування нашої авіакомпанії знаходяться там.
Зараз там працюють 5 наших літаків "Руслан", які виконують роботу в інтересах держави Україна і не тільки.
І країн НАТО, і інших закордонних замовників.
Зараз ми не маємо можливості робити базове технічне обслуговування наших літаків на нашому рідному аеродромі.
Тому всі роботи і важкі роботи ми виконуємо в Німеччині.
За це я дуже вдячний нашим німецьким колегам.
Ми дуже їм вдячні і ми маємо змогу працювати на користь нашої країни,
яка зараз веде дуже винищувальну війну з агресором.
Тим часом в аеропорту "Гостомель" триває розбір знищеного літака АН-225 "Мрія".
Носової частини літака вже не існує, знищена кабіна пілота та все радіонавігаційне обладнання.
Та є те, що вціліло.
Залишилось декілька систем.
Це системи підготовки повітря, системи конденсування повітря.
І є стійки шасі, які ми плануємо використати на другому екземплярі літака.
Кілька двигунів теж вдалося відремонтувати і поставити на інші літаки.
Вже два двигуни працюють на наших літаках в Німеччині.
Ви бачите, що взагалі на літаку шість двигунів.
Три з них ми вже демонтували і відремонтували.
І два з них вже працюють на літаках АН-124-100.
Ми з цього літака демонтували елементи механізації крила,
які теж будуть використовуватись на другому екземплярі літака.
Одразу після деокупації аеропорту "Гостомель" підприємство "Антонов"
почало попереднє проєктування, випуск та розробку документації на відновлення пошкоджених агрегатів "Мрії".
Ми плануємо відремонтувати частину агрегатів, які були пошкоджені на цьому літаку.
В нас частина агрегатів для цього літака є.
І, звичайно, ми плануємо виконати модернізацію систем цього літака.
Програма модернізації насамперед передбачає заміну застарілого обладнання,
скорочення льотного екіпажу, встановлення новітньої авіоніки
та сучасного пілотажного авіаційного обладнання.
Це обладнання, яке забезпечує виконання літаками Ан-124-100 і Ан-225
сучасних вимог міжнародних, які стосуються і захисту навколишнього середовища,
і виконання певних навігаційних специфікацій, і забезпечення радіозв'язку,
забезпечення встановлення аварійно-ритуального обладнання сучасного.
І таких робіт дуже-дуже багато.
Більша частина вже реалізована на літаках Ан-124-100, тому ми будемо використовувати ці напрацювання.
Робити точну копію "Мрії" – недоцільно, каже генеральний конструктор ДП "Антонов".
Адже деякі компоненти неможливо відтворити, а дещо – коштуватиме надто дорого.
Ми розуміємо, що цей літак в єдиному екземплярі,
і ці витрати, які потрібно буде виконати на дослідно-конструкторські роботи,
на проведення його сертифікацій, навряд чи ми зможемо їх окупити.
Тому при формуванні попереднього технічного вигляду цього літака зараз після відновлення,
ми, власне, і керувалися таким підходом, і намагалися зробити необхідний мінімум змін для того,
щоб цей літак поставити на крило, забезпечити його льотну придатність на найближчі декілька років.
Компанія Microsoft у програмі Flight Simulator вже зробила онлайн-літак АН-225.
Гроші, які будуть зароблені з продажів цього продукту,
підуть на відновлення другого екземпляра "Мрії".
За попередніми оцінками, відновлення АН-225 коштуватиме 500 мільйонів євро,
але ця цифра може змінюватися. Кошти збиратимуть усім світом.
Та, крім відновлення "Мрії" і ремонту пошкоджених літаків,
у підприємства "Антонов" є багато планів.
Частину з них поки тримають у таємниці.
Дійсно, ми дуже багато працюємо над відновленням нашого підприємства.
Оскільки ми зазнали досить серйозних пошкоджень, руйнувань.
Наша льотно-випробувальна база, аеродром базування наших літаків дуже сильно пошкоджений,
багато споруд зруйновано, багато втрачено обладнання.
Можливість виконувати випробувальні польоти для нас є критичною.
Тому це один із напрямків.
Ми відновлюємо інфраструктуру нашого підприємства, яка теж зазнала руйнувань після 24 лютого.
Основна наша мета – це збереження колективу,
не просто збереження кількості людей, які працюють,
але і збереження, і власне розвиток їхньої компетенцій.
Крім того, підприємство налагоджує співпрацю з міжнародними партнерами,
у тому числі з компаніями-лідерами в авіаційній галузі.
А сам аеропорт Гостомель, площею приблизно 400 га, по суті, відбудують наново.
Там планують створити вантажний аеропорт-хаб з пасажирським терміналом.